american and russian diplomats are
meeting in geneva switzerland this
morning to try to defuse a potential
military showdown in ukraine the u.s is
worried that russia could invade its
neighbor the way it did back in 2014
when russia seized the crimean
peninsula holly williams is visiting the
frontier in eastern ukraine speaking to
military leaders who are preparing for
war and hoping to prevent another armed
takeover
on ukraine's frozen front line we
trekked through the icy trenches that
sliced this country into
ukraine is an american ally
fighting a bloody russian-backed
rebellion since 2014
more than 14 000 have been reported
killed
in a long time commander andre is a
22-year military veteran and he's
worried a very big possibility a very
big possibility that the russians will
invade yes yes
this winter russia has massed up to a
hundred thousand troops along ukraine's
border
some believe a russian ground invasion
moving in tanks and artillery is
unlikely until the ground here freezes
over but here in the trenches they've
told us it could happen at any time
president vladimir putin claims russia's
a victim of western aggression and he's
demanding security guarantees from
america and its nato allies including
removing nato troops from much of
eastern europe i think that putin is
upset some here say it's a game of cold
war style brinkmanship he wants to be
treated like a great leader he wants
russia to be treated like a great power
that's what he wants and he's using
ukraine as a pawn in a game of chess to
get what he wants absolutely and he
thinks that if he shows his power here
if he shows violence in here in ukraine
western leaders can say well okay we
should deal with putin and should treat
him like we used to treat soviet union
and communist leaders
the us is training ukraine's front-line
soldiers supplying nearly half a billion
dollars in military assistance last year
including anti-tank missiles
in two phone calls with putin last month
president biden threatened moscow with
more sanctions if russia invades but
says he will not send american troops so
it's down here in ukraine's capital kiev
they've renovated old bomb shelters in
case of attack it's a manually operated
air filtration
this one was built during the cold war
when ukraine was part of the soviet
union and ironically america was the
enemy
back on the front line they want no part
of a new russian empire even if it means
the ultimate sacrifice all my soldiers
in
this time ready for
for battle you're all ready to die yes
to save ukraine yes from a russian
invasion not only all my soldiers for
cbs morning's holly williams in eastern
ukraine